on these cold winter nights
I honestly can't think of anything better than
flaky roti and a flavoursome curry
I actually spotted this recipe on the cover of the latest dish magazine
and when I saw it I knew I needed to eat it immediately
I started on my marinade by popping my chicken and with some Greek yoghurt
lime juice gramme masala turmeric
sea salt and ground white pepper
I pop that in the fridge for a few hours and meanwhile got started on my roti
I sifted 4 cups of plain white flour
added a couple of knobs of cold butter
added about a teaspoon and a half of salt
drizzle of olive oil and a cup of boiling water
give that a little mix and then added another half cup of boiling water
once the dough was starting to come together
I kneaded it on the bench for about 5 minutes before setting it aside to rest
then I got started on my curry sauce
in a hot wok I combined oil
onion salt
garlic ginger
chillies and unroasted cashews
Fried that off until it was fragrant
then popped it in l my food processor with a little bit of water
and mixed it until a paste came together
and now we need to get started on the spices
dry toast cardamom peppercorns
cloves and seeds fenugreek seeds
garam masala ground cumin and white pepper
pop that into my mortar and pestle and then blasted it until it was a powder
and it was about at this point
where I realised that this recipe really is a labour of love
melt together some oil and butter
then pop in your curry sauce and fry that off for a few minutes
before adding your marinated chicken
stir in your spices and let that cook for a bit
then I added a bit more natural Greek yoghurt
some water and half a cup of cream
mix that all together and then just let it simmer
then I turned my attention back to my roti
I rolled it into balls then rolled it out
brushed it with melted butter and oil
sprinkled it with flour and then folded it up and then folded it again
once it was all rolled up
then I kinda gently pulled it apart back into a circular shape
and then I gave it one final shaping
I popped that into a hot dry pan
and then the plan here I think is just to keep it moving
so I was spinning it and flipping it
before brushing it with some oil and butter mix
and flipping it some more
I want it to cook and get golden brown but not burnt
once all of the roti was cooked
I plated up my curry and my rice and I pop some roti on the side
topped it with fresh coriander
and oh my goodness I wish you could smell my house
this meal was so hearty, so flavoursome
and yeah it took forever but it was worth it